welcome to this video are playing chess
burglar from Brazil and probably an Enzo
yep let's play something else i'm
usually playing the same ish but check
aha taking on c3 without being provoked
to do so yeah thats that's an option
it's probably not having a big drawback
interesting very interesting yeah i'd
like to play a 384-well f3 though he
might play night age 5 ok but i can i
can just go to f2 yeah it's not a
problem ok hmm yeah that's that's that's
interesting now how to how to develop
hmm now H voice just good right yeah
just H for me as a good move threatening
to take and play G form and the Sun sets
black ok
hmm wow interesting I can take you tease
come Knight to f4
take stakes g49 f1 hmm I can also play G
for now my death one hmm they're also
looks like we nee for it's not bad at
all Queen eight for trying to hinder his
long castle he will cancel long I mean
discern this is no doubt about that
interesting
very complicated position
candy castle long anyway I'm going I can
take this an app like a lot not afford
that really an idea Wow interesting yeah
now I had thought about this anyway
going for Bishop to age three here but
this makes a this idea of more
attractive there's also see five as a as
a move Bishop age three okay
okay he's not threatening to take him a
question is is he threatening to take on
H fry probably it's not okay still I'd
like to keep this closed just to have a
stable position on the Kings side what
I'd love to do lilius get the Knight to
f5 or d5 not f1 III this would be would
be just brilliant but not sure that I
managed that my definitely can just take
yeah this this I didn't I didn't really
believe in because d5 what we're going
there come on it's a plane night okay
well I can just take this alack yeah oh
I was just about to saying it's a play
night f8 and then he didn't that's four
that's funny yeah night here but this is
a position where I'm just just
controlling heart too much space i
believe how is he going to untangle
himself it's it's tricky I cannot move
this night because of T sunny probably
needs to play this then this ma'am and I
have lots of ideas to improve and at the
end they will if they look Emmy for a
five is very good for what yeah I guess
I mean black black possess blacks
position looks critical but here the
compass just saying that this is good
for black really that's heartbreaking
after this he wants he wants night d to
c 5 yeah okay tactics are more important
than positional considerations if this
is working at
working I mean even if King e7 and no
one was completely bonkers if this is a
good move and it's a good move what can
you do so what should I do h5 then is a
mistake funny enough long castles and is
the computer suggestion yeah well h5
wasn't really essential but that's
really weird you know so long castles
then interesting yeah and this is really
unplayable mmm amazing that this tactic
while I didn't look for so so concrete
lines like like this CM and it's really
just giving away the pawn line this is
completely lost amazing alright thanks
for watching